hey little guys my name is Luciano
welcome to another video today what are
we talking about functions and C++ what
a midweek video am i dreaming has Jono
gone crazy maybe but that's not the
point I just want to say a huge thank
you for everyone who's been drawing this
series I'm really glad you guys are
enjoying this because it's been a real
blast to me if you want to show me how
much you appreciate my videos you can
follow me on Instagram link in the
description below lately I've been
really into photography and it would
mean the world to me if you guys could
follow me
just like pause this video right now and
just go and follow me anyway back to
functions so what exactly are functions
functions are basically blocks of code
that we write that are designed to
perform a specific task later when we
get to classes those blocks are called
methods but when I say functions I'm
explicitly talking about something that
isn't part of a class it's pretty common
for us to split up functions to prevent
code duplication we don't want to be
running the same code multiple times
because of course if we did apart from
copying and pasting a lot of code and
just ending up with this huge mess it
also means that if we decide to change
some code we have to change it in all
those places where we pasted the
original code and that's just going to
be a disaster to maintain so what we can
do instead is just write a nice little
function that does what we want it to
and then we can call it multiple times
in our code if we need to you can think
of functions of having an input and an
output although they don't necessarily
need to we can provide the function with
certain parameters and the function can
return a value for us so suppose that we
wanted to multiply two numbers together
and we wanted to write a function that
did that so the first thing I'm going to
write here is something called a return
value that is this is the type that this
function will return since we're
multiplying two integers that of course
will result in an integer so our return
type is going to be int I'm going to
give the function a name in this case
multiplier and it's going to take two
parameters these are actually the
numbers that we want to multiply
together I'll just call them a and B
I'll give the function a body and all
this is going to do is return a times B
so you can see that we've got a function
here that takes in two parameters both
integers and simply returns the product
of those two numbers we don't
necessarily have to provide parameters
for example I could just not provide any
parameters and return something like
five times eight this is still a
function that returns
integer but it is just not taking any
parameters we could also tell the
function that we don't want it to return
anything and we do that by writing void
as its return type void of course means
nothing so instead this could do
something like love the result to the
console so let's go back to our original
example here where we had n a and int B
and we returned the product of those two
integers so how do we call this function
well calling a function is pretty simple
let's go ahead and try and print the
result of a multiplication I'm going to
first of all make a variable which holds
this result so I'll type end result
equals multiply and we'll go with 3 and
2 so what this is going to do is call
this multiply function with these two
parameters and then store the return
value that is this result of a times B
in this result integer we can then
output that result to the console
let's hit f5 to run our program and our
fruit builds you can see that we get 6
which of course is what three times two
is so let's kick this up a notch suppose
that I want to do a bunch of
multiplications and I want to log all of
them to the console if I do something
like that without a function then it
would look pretty messy so for example I
need to repeat this code so let's go
ahead and copy and paste a few time I'll
call it something like result two result
three will do eight times five 90 times
45 and if I run my program and oh hang
on a minute why am I getting the same
value everywhere oh look when I copied
and pasted this code I forgot to change
the variable now you may have thought
that I did that by accident but I
actually did it on purpose to prove
something this actually happens all the
time people copy and paste blocks of
code and then forget change one minor
detail and in certain situations you
might actually just run your program and
not even notice that it's not working
correctly until it breaks somewhere down
the line and yet something like this can
actually be fixed really easily if you
just create a function for it let's go
ahead and fix this by actually printing
out results two and three if I run this
we will get our correct results which is
great however you can see that I'm
actually calling this multiple times and
it's just a little bit annoying like for
example further down the road if I
decide to replace this multiply function
by simply from doing something like
eight times five look at this I have to
replace it in every single place three
times two
90 times 45 that's I want to have to
deal with that so this multiplication
and then logging the result let's go
ahead and make the function for that
it'll be void because it's not really
going to return anything to us it's just
going to perform what we asked it to do
we'll call it something like multiply
and log and then let's take a look at
which parameters we might want so what
actually changes between these three
blocks of code the values that we
actually multiplied that's it
so those become the parameters for our
function what actually changes between
these doctor probe what needs to be
specified for this function to perform
its job let's go ahead and write in our
parameters so we're going to be taking
in two integers and be using a really
cool them anything you want that MV
seems sensible we'll copy and paste one
of these blocks into this function this
looks pretty good of course I'll replace
three and two with our parameters so
that we're using the parameters we
specify into this function to perform
the multiplication against which will
cause a times B to get multiplied here
and then we're going to be logging our
results the consult so now instead of
doing this so many times all I have to
do is simply call multiply and log with
my parameters so three and two for
example and then we have eight and five
and then we have 90 and 45 and that's it
look at that I can get rid of all this
code and this is what we end up with a
nice clean and easy to read program if I
launch my program you can see that we
get the correct values here so this is a
pretty simple example but I think it's
effective in demonstrating that
functions are really really important
you should be aiming to split up your
code into many many functions however
one thing that I want to stress is don't
go overboard you don't need a function
for absolutely every line of code that's
not going to be good for anyone it's
going to be hard to maintain your code
is going to look messy and cluttered and
it's actually going to make your program
slower every time we call a function
asterisk the compiler generates a call
instruction what it basically means is
that in a running program in order for
us to call a function we need to create
the entire stack frame for the function
meaning we have to push things like the
parameters onto the stack we have to
also push something called a return
address onto the stack and then what we
do is we actually jump to a different
part of our binary in order to start
executing the instructions from our
function and that return value that we
push we need to get back to where we
originally were before we call the
function so this is called like jumping
around memory in order to execute
function instructions and all of that
takes time so it slows down our program
now the reason I said asterisk earlier
was because this is all assuming that
the compiler decides to keep our
function as an actual function and
doesn't inline it we're going to talk in
depth about inlining in a future video
so the reason I'm saying all this is
because you don't want to just go ahead
and create a functions absolutely every
line of code don't be ridiculous about
it it takes a little bit of experience
to realize what you need a function for
but basically if you see yourself doing
a common task
multiple times create a function for
that the primary point of functions is
to prevent code duplication we don't
want to just be copying and pasting code
everywhere
now if we go back to our code for just a
second you might have noticed something
a little bit odd about this main
function it says that it's return value
is int however the return keyword is
nowhere to be found and I'm obviously
not returning anything so if I specify a
return value do I actually need to
return something let's go ahead and try
and just do nothing in this multiply
function I'll hit control f7 to compile
my file
look at this I'm getting an error
telling me that multiply must return a
value
so do functions with the return type
actually need to return values the
answer is yes they do the main function
is actually a special function the main
function and only the main function is
exempt from this kind of must return a
value if you don't specify a return
value it will automatically assume that
you're returning zero so we'll be
identical to if I had written this this
is just a feature of modern CNC but lost
versions that lets you just keep your
code a little bit cleaner and just as
fun know that this must return a value
thing is actually something that only
applies in debug mode we compile in
release mode here you'll see that we
actually don't get an error that's not
to say that what we're doing here is
correct because if we actually do
capture that return value so to do
something we will get undefined behavior
it's just as the compiler won't actually
yell at us
however in debug mode with certain debug
compilation flags enabled we will get an
error which will just help us debug our
code because at no point should you be
writing a function
it's going to return something but
doesn't okay so that's pretty much a
basic introduction to functions
functions are really useful I'm going to
be writing a lot more of them in the
future every program is built from a
collection of functions so this is
really important stuff if you don't
think you fully understand how functions
work don't worry because throughout this
series we're going to be writing so many
functions that you're just going to get
used to it and the best way to learn is
of course to practice we also commonly
break up functions into declarations and
definitions so declarations we usually
store in header file and then
definitions we write in translation unit
or CPP files so now I'm going to make a
whole video dedicated to header files
and we're going to cover function
declarations in a header file in that
video so anyway guys I hope you enjoyed
this episode if you did please hit the
like button don't forget to follow me on
Twitter and Instagram and if you really
enjoy this video and you want to see
drafts of future videos early as well as
discuss what actually goes into these
videos you can support me on patreon
link will be in description below but
until next time guys goodbye
[Music]